et on va tout de suite justement en
pologne retrouver notre envoyé spécial
emmanuel chasse des manuels plus de la
moitié des ukrainiens qui ont fuit le
pays arrive en pologne c'est le premier
pays d'accueil vous assistez à un élan
de solidarité sur place c'est cela
oui tout à fait la pologne vraiment qui
accueille qui a accueilli jusqu'à ce
jour depuis le 24 février plus de 1,7
million d'ukrainiens parfois plus de
cent mille personnes par jour à médical
où je me trouvais un peu plus tôt et
bien c'était vingt mille personnes par
jour ces derniers jours d'aidé après
l'agression russe en ukraine et bien il
ya eu toute cette population qui qui
s'est dirigé vers la pologne et
l'accueil effectivement été celui d'une
grande solidarité et du côté citoyen il
ya énormément de polonais qui ont ouvert
leur maison qui héberge désormais des
ukrainiens il faut savoir qui est aussi
une forte communauté ukrainienne est
déjà bien avant cette agression russe en
ukraine une forte communauté chrétienne
ici en pologne près de deux millions de
personnes donc ce qu'on a assisté aux
premières semaines pendant les premières
semaines ça a été des gens qui sont
venus rejoindre leur famille mais
évidemment un plus grande échelle et a
reçu des initiatives comme
réquisitionner les écoles ici dans cette
région frontalière afin de permettre
d'établir des centres d'hébergement
d'urgence donc la pologne très fortement
mobilisée pour pour accueillir ces
millions de personnes qui arrivent
chaque jour qui continuaient d'arriver
qui continuent d'arriver chaque jour à
ces postes frontières on attendait
également les ong sont elles arrivées
sur place
elles commencent à arriver elles sont de
plus en plus présentes vous voyez
dernièrement il ya des pompiers ce sont
des pompiers volontaires français ils se
trouvent sur plusieurs postes aux
frontières le long de la frontière il ya
des associations des ong qui sont
représentées de tous les pays des ong
américaine irlandaise indienne chinoise
britannique qui se déplace là un pardon
la rm lio m l'office internationale pour
les migrations est également présent
c'étaient des semaines placent alors
elle a été un peu lente à se mettre en
place aujourd'hui à medica qui se trouve
à environ 40 kilomètres d'ici et bien
les nations unies sont arrivés donc
c'est presque trois semaines après le
début de cet exode massif de réfugiés
venus d'ukraine donc une aide qui est
présente qui s'organise qui est encore
en fait en plein tâtonnements alors que
les gens continuent d'arriver par
milliers tous les jours ici en pologne
merci emmanuel emmanuel chain en direct
de la frontière polonaise